Stanley spent most of his career as the
writer director editor and producer of
Marvel Comics he created some of the
world's most popular comic book
characters like Spider Man Iron Man The
Hulk and the rest of the Avengers while
started out as the creative ideas of a
teenage boy evolved into one of the most
profitable movie franchises in all of
history
sambaiah graphics we're going to talk
about the legendary life of Stan Lee
[Music]
on December the 28th of 1922 Stanley
Martin Lieber was born in New York City
his parents Jack and Celia were Romanian
Jewish immigrants who left for a better
life in the United States his father was
a tailor but he was laid off during the
Great Depression so they were constantly
struggling to make rent his parents
could only afford a one-bedroom
apartment and they did their best to
provide for their son his mother and
father slept on the couch and allowed
him to have a real bed most of the
memories Stanley had of his father was
seeing him sitting at the kitchen table
flipping through the want ads in the
newspaper trying to find a new job these
were usually gigs that never lasted very
long eventually his father would find
steady work and their lives would
improve at least a little when he was
nine years old his mother gave birth to
his younger brother Larry now I'm saying
yeah he got a bicycle for Christmas Stan
took this opportunity to ride his bike
all over New York City and hardly spent
any time at home getting to know his
younger brother since his parents were
struggling so much with money they
encouraged Stan to get good grades so
that he would have a brighter future
than they did and they encouraged him to
find part-time jobs as soon as he could
he took this very seriously and even
skipped a few grades so that he could
graduate from high school sooner he
attended an all-boys school and since he
was so much smaller and younger than his
classmates he struggled to make friends
he was often daydreaming about his
favorite movies and often had his nose
in a book as soon as he was old enough
to work he got his first job at a
garment factory the year later he moved
on to become an usher at a movie theater
called the Rivoli he loved this job
because he was allowed to see as many
movies as he wanted for free it was also
able to make money doing something that
he enjoyed and it also helped him to
relieve his parents financial stress he
began to pay for his own expenses so
that his parents could focus mostly on
his brother Larry even at a young age as
parents and teachers could tell that he
would grow up to be someone special at
this stage in his life Stan imagined
that he would be more involved in the
movie business as either an actor or
maybe a screenwriter his favorite movie
growing up was the 1935 film Captain
Blood which was about swashbuckling
pirate adventures he loved the elaborate
fight scenes and would often imagine
becoming the hero of these films at 15
years old Stan entered a right
contest for the New York Herald Tribune
he won and the editor reached out to him
to say that he should pursue writing as
a full-time career seeing as he had
graduated high school early he was able
to get a job writing obituaries for a
newspaper but after a while he felt that
this was pretty boring and indeed quite
morbid so he tried to see what other
opportunities were out there for young
writers at 16 years old he got a job at
timely comics assisting that artist Jack
Kirby and the head writer and editor Joe
Simon the overarching publishing company
actually made most of their income from
pulp fiction and comics were more of an
afterthought for them in the beginning
Stan was pretty much hard just to make
coffee and I raised the pencil marks on
Jack Kirby's drawings as well as do
various other errands his income was
only eight dollars a week and if we
consider inflation that's about 141
dollars today so back then timely comics
followed the trends of whatever was
popular at the time now DC comics were
their main competitor and they had
Superman so the characters they created
were often they recycle idea in one way
or another at this point in time Jack
Kirby and Joe Simon had already been
inventing superheroes like the Human
Torch and Captain America Stan was eager
to move on from just making coffee so he
pitched a story for a Captain America
scripts after the third issue was
published they liked his ideas and they
agreed to use it in the following issue
this is when he decided that his pen
name would be Stanley which is just his
first name Stanley split in half he
figured that someday he could move on to
become a novelist under his real name
Stanley Martin Lieber when he was 18
years old Stanley he had been working at
timely comics for two years and he was
assisting Jack Kirby and Joe Simon with
all the various duties of their company
both Kirby and Simon were having a
financial dispute with Marvel Comics as
publisher Martin Goodman and they
decided to quit Stan was the only one
left and his boss asked him if he would
be willing to step into the role of head
writer editor and art director this was
meant to be a temporary fix while
Goodman searched for an experienced
replacement of it Stan actually ended up
being great at doing all of these jobs
at once at the time he mainly focused on
producing the Captain America comics
because you know there's only 24 hours
in a day and he already had his work cut
out for him at that time
Kovach industry it was absolutely
booming because people they wanted to
escape the fears that they had about the
war by reading stories of heroes both in
the newspapers and in fiction world war
ii at this point it was absolutely
raging Jack Kirby and Joe Simon that
already established a theme of Captain
America coming face to face with that
off Hitler on more than one occasion so
Stanley carried on their legacy by
acting out his fantasies of being in
combat overseas Captain America comics
and spired Stanley to become a real hero
himself he stated I myself got so caught
up in all of that next thing I knew I
had enlisted in the army I felt our
nation was really in danger and I
couldn't live with myself if I were a
civilian and other people were over
there fighting however Stanley was not
expected to go overseas and fight the
army recruiter looked over his resume
and gave him the job of playwright he
was told to stay in the United States
and write scripts for training films and
public service announcements that were
shown to soldiers even if this was not
exactly the fight that Stan was looking
for this was actually a pretty big deal
and all of the army playwrights went on
to have successful careers including
Theodor Geisel who is better known as
dr. Seuss so when he was 23 years old
Stanley was discharged from the Army and
he moved back to New York City to return
to his job where the name had been
changed from timely comics to Marvel
Comics
[Music]
when sternly returned to New York City
he began to go out on dates and attend a
lot of parties indeed he was actually
pretty embarrassed to tell people that
he worked for Marvel a lot of women
would actually just walk away
mid-conversation as soon as they heard
him say comic books clearly these girls
were not the one theme
all his life Stan would be doodling
pictures of the perfect girl that he
always imagines that he would find
someday and it was like he could see a
vision of the future
one night he showed up to a party when a
young women named Joan Clayton answered
the door Stan was shocked because this
was the exact same girl II had been
dreaming about his entire life he
blurted out hello I think I'm gonna fall
in love with you
Joan laughed and she thought this and
the fact that he wrote comics was
actually quite charming
the only issue was that she was married
to someone else she was originally from
England and she had become a war bride
and moved to the United States with a
new husband to pursue her modeling and
acting career she and her first husband
they were no longer happy together and
once she met Stan she knew that it was
time to make her divorce official when
Stanley was 25 the do you got married
and instead of having a fancy wedding or
a honeymoon they used that money to move
to Long Island where they lived in a
penthouse apartment when Joan first got
pregnant she painted their entire house
pink because she wanted a daughter so
badly this barely worked and she gave
birth to a baby girl named June junior
who they nicknamed JC a couple of years
later there's a second daughter named
Jen
sadly Jen died after only being alive
for seven days this was such a traumatic
experience for Joan that she didn't want
to have children again they cried - a
dog was they run into a lot of issues
since Dan was Jewish and Joan was
Episcopalian nearly every adoption
agency rejected them because of the
differences in religious beliefs while
all of this was very tragic and
difficult for Stanley and his wife it
opened up his eyes to so many issues in
the country that he had been unaware of
until this point indeed it would become
a catalyst for his motivation to inspire
other people
at work Stanley was still incredibly
dedicated with his time of Marvel Comics
they called their staff the bullpen
because they were pumping out one
complete comic every working day he made
sure to give everyone on the team credit
with their names on the cover of each
comic book which was brand new for the
time he also gave the group the nickname
of the merry Marvel marching Society
after he established more of a
leadership role in the company Stan
eventually convinced artist Jack Kirby
to return to Marvel Comics since he was
one of the most talented men in the
business Kirby's artwork brought Stan
Lee's ideas to life in a way that no one
else could even though he was not an
actor in the traditional sense Stan was
known for acting out the roles of the
characters when working as Marvel's
editor and art director in order to
explain what he was looking for in the
storyline rather than giving an artist a
fully written script to follow Stan Lee
would give them a general storyline of
what was going to happen and see he
wanted everything to be overly dramatic
like people in a silent film once the
artwork was done Stan would go back and
fill in the bubbles with the appropriate
dialogue this cut down on time
significantly and it was called the
Marvel method in the 1950s a
psychologist named Frederick Wert
enclave's that comic books and
television were corrupting the youth in
America in 1954 the Senate Subcommittee
on juvenile delinquency announced that
comic books were actually dangerous
they started the comics code Authority
which put strict rules of censorship on
what types of content were to be allowed
to be published in comic books every new
storyline had to be approved by the
comics code Authority and the cover of
the book would have the seal showing
that it had been checked for any
indecent content according to the rules
the mention of any crime at all was
enough to have a comic rejected this
censorship it was a devastating blow to
Marvel who made their bread and butter
on superhero stories about fighting
crime Stan Lee had to lay off almost all
of the artists and they had to
discontinue many of their comics he was
forced to write new stories that were
aimed at young children and they were
incredibly bland and boring compared to
writing about superheroes Stan Lee
trudged through this job over a decade
after working in the comic book industry
for 20 years Stan Lee was having a bit
of a midlife crisis he had been writing
these silly children's comics for so
long that
he really wasn't sure he wanted to stay
in the industry indeed he was already
writing screenplays and newspaper
articles on the side and he was
considering leaving the comic book
industry in order to write a novel the
only problem was that he still had a
wife and child to support and he
couldn't walk away from a paycheck he
had a conversation with his wife Joan
and she encouraged him to take a chance
and try to write a comic for adults even
if it went against the censorship rules
they decided that if his publisher hated
it the worst thing that could happen was
that he would be fired but well he was
ready to quit anyway so you really have
nothing left to lose this is when he
decided to create the Fantastic Four
these characters they're
multi-dimensional they didn't always
enjoy having their superpowers they
don't with very real issues with one
another as well as they're in a turmoil
at that time superheroes from both
companies they were really
one-dimensional characters like Captain
America or Superman
it turns out that the audience responded
really well to the Fantastic Four and
this ended up becoming extremely
successful Marvel's publisher couldn't
deny the numbers so they continued to
make more issues despite the disapproval
and lack of stamp from the comics code
Authority once he was able to express
his ideas within the pages of Marvel
Comics Stan Lee discovered a new love of
the industry he began to create more
characters like Spider Man who he based
on himself as a teenager each one of
these characters was a direct reaction
to the world around him for example the
Hulk was written during the Cold War
when people were afraid of nuclear
science Iron Man was a response to the
hate for the military-industrial complex
and the x-men were a social commentary
on tolerance for people who are
different from us in 1966 Stan Lee
created Black Panther who was the
world's first black superhero
he was revolutionising to the industry
in just about every single way during an
interview Stan Lee said that the 1960s
and 70s were some of the best years of
his entire career he began going on tour
to universities around the United States
by this point the children who grew up
in the 1950s that were told that comic
books would corrupt their impressionable
minds were embracing them once they
reached their teens and their twenties
young people everywhere looked up to
Stan Lee and he gave lectures on story
writing in reality Stan Lee was
gathering data on his fans and after
every Q&A session he was writing down
it's about ways that he could improve
the Marvel Comics storylines
[Music]
in the 1970s Stanley became the head
publisher of Marvel he decided to hand
over the responsibilities of the scripts
to other writers on the Marvel team as
he tried to take the superhero
characters to California he convinced
the executives at Marvel Comics to let
him move his family out to Los Angeles
and they opened up new officers called
Marvel productions on the west coast
he started the cartoon series of Iron
Man and one called spider-man and his
amazing friends in 1988 he became the
head of Marvel films and began to
produce feature-length movies this ended
up being a great business move because
spider-man soon became a household name
unfortunately not everything that Marvel
Studios produced was a success they
tried to create a show called the
amazing spider-man which aired on CBS
but Stan Lee he thought it was awful he
scheduled a meeting with CBS and tried
to give some creative direction about
how to make the story better but they
ignored his input and carried on doing
it their way they should have listened
to his advice because the show is
cancelled after just four episodes
Hollywood studios were having a hard
time seeing the potential of these
comic-book stories and didn't know how
they put them on the big screen Lee
stated is hard to explain the
frustration we had these characters and
we knew how they should be portrayed and
there were people who wanted to do them
but nothing really gelled in 1997 the
popularity of comic books dropped
dramatically children were still
watching the Marvel animated series like
x-men on Saturday mornings but the
profits of the company went really
downhill while it seems almost
impossible to imagine this today Marvel
Comics
actually had to file for bankruptcy
thankfully even though the company was
broke they still maintain the copyright
to all of their characters which was a
gold mine during this time of
uncertainty Stan Lee was approached by
investors he suggested that he start a
whole new company called Stan Lee Media
which specialized in creating cartoons
and comics that were streamed on the
Internet they started in 1999 and the
venture became incredibly successful
they were able to hire over 200 people
to work on their staff unfortunately
some of the executives were actually
arrested for securities fraud it turns
out they had taken advantage of Stan
Lee's name and his reputation for their
own financial gain
Stan Lee decided that the only way to
avoid the scandal was to start his own
company called POW entertainment one of
his most popular characters
was stripper Ella voiced by Pamela
Anderson eventually Marvel was able to
get back on their feet and they had
Stanley under contract so that they
could continue to get its creative
guidance to make sure that the movies
were done right after decades of
dreaming of being on the big screen
Stanley was finally about to appear in
Hollywood blockbusters because he made
sure that his contract included cameo
roles in each new Marvel movie that came
out for the rest of his life retirements
was not an option for Stanley he loved
his job that much Stanley Martin Lieber
he passed away on November the 12th 2018
it was 95 years old and lives every
moment to the fullest with a sense of
joy and enthusiasm even if the man is
gone the legend of Stanley will live on
forever as being one of the most
influential people in comic book history
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe about brand new
videos just like this every day of the
week but if you're looking for something
else to watch right now why not check
out some of the videos I'm linking to on
the screen and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]